like to commit a little bestiality with
this next filly I'm not so sure this
isn't some rich guys creative use of a
hooker if she breaks a nail I think
you're allowed to shoot her
unfortunately she didn't make the cut
for the tosh.0 Preakness
[Music]
and
[Applause]
and the jumpy on something racist looks
you aliens when he gets the roses and
the Jumbo catnap talking here yes there
were boys riding our naked bodies but we
were pretending to be horses and horses
don't wear pants these telenovelas are
getting goddamn ridiculous what a sexy
equestrian the scenery the Spanish
narration it's all very romantic this
may be the most beautiful video I've
ever seen come on Lee say no it's not
Peyton Manning getting limber in the
offseason
that's a horse doing yoga that filly
really wants a great ass she should do
horse Pilates all the exercise in the
world won't help that face don't forget
to point your hugs beats getting whipped
for three miles of the Kentucky Derby my
yoga instructor almost never kisses me
just dip your junk and salt already I'd
like to place a $10 exacta that the
jockey finishes first
and they're off just screwin the stables
that's how he became the horse Pfister
and before three of you tell me you
already saw this video on @midnight
know that I found out about it after it
was too late to make a change maybe I
should watch the show more I do I like
to play along at home as soon as anyone
yells points I turn off my TV for that
we say namaste hey looks like the Tooth
Fairy will be making an unexpected visit
tonight well it's hard to walk it off
when you haven't learned to walk
it's okay a kid's head can be shaped
back to round the first two years bad
news guys her parents had no choice they
had to put that rocking horse down it's
on her who goes horseback riding in
their jammies
[Music]
finally an equestrian event for poor
girls whose parents can't afford to buy
them a horse but can afford broom
handles yes this is a real thing my only
problem is you can't gamble on it that's
why I created my office's annual triple
Kentucky hobby horse Derby Preakness
Stakes at Belmont crown we're still
working on that title it's that time of
the year again folks lots of people
placing bets on the stakes are high in
post position one we've got game for pay
at five-to-one odds in post position two
stupid mother long shot at $75
Anderson pooper in post position three a
very clear favor today
mrs. hands in post position four at ten
to one post position five is in the lead
at three to one and rounding out the
field in post position six is that
feeling again when you can't remember if
you locked your front door at 20 to one
here's a good sign that feeling again
when you can't remember if you're locked
your front door just pooped on the track
the jockey seems to be having a hard
time getting in the lead to calm down in
the starting gate
batting is officially closed and we're
ready to start real races for second and
third ladies and gentleman that feeling
you get when you can't remember if your
locked front door tries to get by but
gave up a staying strong that feeling
again when you can't remember if you
locked you front or no gave up a caper
Bay is really hugging the rail here we
go coming around the turn and down the
stretch and yes he's done Anderson
Cooper for the win gave up a squeaks out
second followed by that feeling again
when he can't remember if you locked
your front toe up a third stupid mother
misses hands and in the lead finishing
up last with a snapped stick what an
amazing day on the track not since an
orphanage in the 40s have I seen so many
depressing stick tours
me and my friends at PETA won't stop
until every animal is a stick animal
you